dans cette piscine allemande des
échauffourés impliquant des jeunes
immigrés on conduit à la fermeture de
deux établissements ça s'est passé dans
ce quartier de nocoln ou la police a dû
intervenir pour mettre un terme à des
violences et faire évacuer les visiteurs
la piscine berlinoise de colombiana est
restée fermée une semaine désormais il
faut présenter son sac et ses documents
d'identité pour pouvoir entrer ce
quartier ou vit une grande partie de la
diaspora turque avait déjà été le
théâtre de violence urbaine résultat 3
jours après les échauffourées le
personnel de la piscine a publié une
lettre à sa direction dans le quotidien
de la gauche libéral d’ertag & Spiegel
les employés s'y plaignent de l'ampleur
intolérable des problèmes souvent causés
par des jeunes issus de famille arabes
parfois tchétchen selon eux les femmes
les homosexuels et les trans sont
fréquemment menacés Peter Zain le
président de l'association allemande des
maîtres nageurs pour inclus la
responsabilité de macho ayant immigré et
le fait que différentes couches
culturelles soient représentées dont de
nombreux jeunes hommes issus de
l'immigration le même incident s'est
produit dans la piscine voisine de
primsenbad ou vit aussi une importante
communauté turque le même dimanche un
garçon de 20 ans a importé une jeune
fille de 14 ans le frère de cette
dernière âgé de 17 ans a frappé le
premier qui a été hospitalisé le moindre
motif comme le fait de regarder de
travers ou de bousculer involontairement
quelqu'un conduite à la violence parce
que l'honneur est prétendu bafoué les
jeunes hommes veulent montrer qu'ils
sont les plus forts ces incidents ont
même poussé le groupe des verres
Berlinois qui s'affichent fermement
antiraciste à exiger le refoulement des
têtes brûlées des piscines beaucoup
mettent en cause le modèle multiculturel
allemand au total 150 000 demandes
d'asile ont été déposées au cours du
premier semestre 2023 plus que pour
toute l'année 2021
[Musique]